wie langweilig ist doch die realität
warum auf dem geraden weg der vernunft
bleiben wenn faszinierende ausflüge in
eine andere welt locken
ausflüge in ein verändertes bewusstsein
vom rauschtrinken über party fehlen vom
dampfenden joint bis zu lsd und heroin
die auswahl der substanzen kennt keine
grenzen
mal sollen sie entspannen mal antreiben
oder befreien
mal werden sie gefördert mal sind sie
verboten einige machen süchtig und krank
die unterscheidung zwischen genussmittel
heilmittel und droge scheint nicht immer
klar
der chemiker albert hofmann entdeckte
1938 in basel eine substanz mit namen
lsd
damit löste er eine weltweite forschungs
euphorie aus wie er sich später erinnert
sich aktive verbindung der medizin
biologie der vermieter experimentell
psychiatrie als sehr nützliche wertvolle
rolle spielt und erst sorgen bürger geht
hat man das lsd verwechselt mit dem
actros mittel
[Musik]
die protestkultur der 68er nahm die
halluzinogene mit begeisterung auf es
war die hohe zeit der psychedelischen
drogen
doch bald machten berichte von psychosen
und tödlichen unfällen unter lsd
einfluss die runde
1971 wurde der stoff in der schweiz
verboten
von nun an galten halluzinogene
substanzen als gefährliche und illegale
drogen
[Musik]
seit den 90er jahren fluten neue
synthetische pillen den schwarzmarkt
zusammen mit lsd kokain ecstasy und co
bevor sie den partyrausch am wochenende
[Musik]
doch im zeitalter der hirnforschung
kommt die hoffnung wieder auf
halluzinogene könnten uns zugang zum
rätsel unseres bewusstseins verschaffen
wissenschaftler untersuchen ob diese
substanzen gegen depressionen und andere
psychische störungen wirksam sein können
besonders im trend bei forschern wie
konsumenten das sogenannte micro dose
kleinste dosen etwa von lsd sollen uns
leistungsfähiger und kreativer machen
was fasziniert uns am rausch geht es um
entgrenzung kontrollverlust ekstase
suchen wir nach verlorenen göttern oder
nur uns selbst braucht es zwingend
substanzen um ihn solche zustände zu
geraten
[Applaus]